okay what do you got let's get kooky
Super Bowl
I heard the Super Bowl let me just say
this but I went to the Super Bowl I did
shrooms I was there and the Rihanna show
was the highlight holy [__] I I was
watching that like oh my God this might
be the most elaborate abortion of all
time yeah
I thought she was gonna fall from that
top deck you know I should warn you I'm
gonna be a little darker than the other
guys well not the black but uh you know
metaphorically darker you know
I like dark humor I'm dead inside uh
we're all gonna die one day it's just
yuck em ups you know all right sorry
give me a give me
circumcising back to the Jews all right
um
well let's see the old anteater they say
it's uh less uh more sensitive if you're
uh uncirced it just it looks like a sea
creature that's the only problem
but it's weird you're allowed to make
fun of guys who are uncircumcised but
that's like body shaming you know and if
you're like hey that lady's fat for like
whoa what the [__] you know but you're
like hey that guy's got a weird dick and
we're like yeah
I guess you can't see the dick all the
time you can see the fat constantly so
that's that's probably what that is but
all right okay that got me in all right
we'll we'll clean it up
New Orleans I heard
oh New Orleans I'm from New Orleans Fun
Town yeah hell of a telephone Town not a
great place to grow up if I'm being
completely honest uh I grew up in a
dilapidated mansion in a poor black
neighborhood and I was raised by a giant
cross-dressing black guy and now I can't
get an erection unless I see a picture
of RuPaul so uh
but great town go visit
burgers
like a hamburger
[Music]
wait wait hold on McDonald's
uh
does anybody eat there anymore
it's weird it's like [__] a hooker
you really just do it when you're drunk
and uh it's late McDonald's used to be
like a normal day we're going to
McDonald's all right Dad thanks and now
it's like ah don't tell anybody and I'm
[__] blood
all right
remember that ball pit too we used to
swim in that ball pit when I was a kid
and uh that must have been full of jizz
you know like uh just jizz and feces and
we were just loving it
yeah
all right sorry
ghost stories ah you gotta hate the guy
who believes in ghosts
um
it's always that one guy hey you know
ghost my grandmother died in here so
watch out you're like
shut up
who cares get out of here hey this place
is haunted all right go kill yourself
Jesus Christ
ghosts are so convenient too it's always
like hey there's a little lady with a
shoe missing and she's it's a little
girl looking for a dolly you know it's
never like ah Isis ghost you know
well it's never something actually scary
and also if they were if it was all dead
people were ghosts would there just be
zillions and zillions of ghosts all the
time we'd just be walking through ghost
[__] and the [__] you know
all right It's too convenient there's no
ghosts
what is it
oysters all right well you know oysters
is a real uh divide it's kind of like
Jews either love them or hate them and
uh
I love them I love them
um oysters
um
I like oysters they're fun the first guy
to eat oyster that guy was [__]
hungry holy [__] no
imagine finding one of those that's a
piece of [__] uh shell here oh there's a
loogie inside all right
maybe on a cracker with some hot sauce
[__] it yeah
those those bastards they charge you
like nine dollars for an oyster it's the
same with uh Lobster Lobster was like
Poor People's [__] food now we're all
like mmm I'll put on a gay bib
that's how you know lobster's expensive
you can wear a bib if you saw a guy at
Waffle House with a bib on you go well
that guy's special needs there you go
but you see a guy with a lobster
everyone you're like
you're like this guy's all right yeah
what's that
Boston oh yeah Boston well you guys are
hanging on to that accent aren't you
I don't know I don't know if anybody
really
cares that much about Boston uh
you know you had the bombing that was
something but now I'm having one but uh
you know
crock pot that was fun
Regis and Kathie Lee what year is it
ma'am
um that has been on in 30. wait to hear
about OJ holy [__] all right this lady's
a little dating
bodegas I like a bodega Good Times Oprah
edging oh I love edging yes you're
talking about when you paint the the
edge of a wall oh oh you're talking
about when you uh you're about to jizz
and you hold it yeah I do that to my
wife all the time but on accident yeah
she's like I'm about to go and I'm like
oh [__] I already went
so yeah I don't know edging it just
feels like if you got an orgasm coming
let it come you know what are we doing
with the holding it back is it you
didn't you're shooting you you blow out
a candle or something you know you're
gonna put someone's eye out with that
edging it's like kicking a hose then you
let it go and it really just ruins that
kid but um all right
okay sorry madam all right
I guess we gotta give it back to the old
uh schnoz over there huh what do you say
all right ah hey all right